(audience applauding)
Please welcome back Erin
and Ben Napier.
My heroes,
and Ben, I am very excited to hear from you
and Erin.
Tell us what you are doing,
because I wanna know some thrifty holiday like, tips.
Well, Erin's laughing here
because like, this is normally her world,
but I am the Christmas King.
It's true.
So, I don't know if y'all are just watching-
He tries to go full Griswold every year.
Every year. Like, this right here.
If this could be our house at Christmas,
It's not quite enough.
They went all out.
So that's that's me. That's how I like to do Christmas.
I go a little more understated.
Yeah, Erin likes,
she likes white lights.
I like this very much.
But this right here,
This is classic Erin Christmas.
This is pretty classic.
So, if you have a yard that has some greenery
that you can clip from the yard,
or some little tiny trees, maybe in your woods,
you could pot at the front door
and then wrap in some Christmas lights,
it doesn't cost anything to use what you already have.
Or if you have like, some pre-lit Christmas trees,
the lights don't work anymore,
you could just cut the top off,
plop it in a little pot by the door,
put some lights on it.
But you can get things like,
you can get little lights,
They're not expensive.
like, at a pharmacy, or a dollar store.
But look at this.
So, you can buy these letters cut out,
at a, you know,
a craft store,
A craft store.
or you can cut them out yourself.
But everybody has this.
Scraps.
Yes, like old t-shirts
Your kids old Christmas jammies,
the ones that they never liked very much,
and you're not gonna cry when you pack in a box.
Well, we have someone, Yvonne Chan.
She's actually here.
She has a question for you guys
Okay.
and we have a little
back story, take a look.
Hi Drew. It's Yvonne.
I have the sad house on the block,
especially when it comes to front door decorations.
It can be expensive
and it's hard to know how to get it just right.
Do you have any tips for me?
Hi Yvonne.
Hi.
Yvonne's here.
(audience applauding)
How are you?
You're like giving me like, Chanel meets Christmas.
I'm liking it.
Okay. Erin, what is your first tip?
Yes, I love what Ben was saying,
when you're like, decorating the outside of your door.
This is just a fun, super inexpensive thing
'cause everybody has old like, clothes, t-shirts.
You could cut this fabric, take these letters,
wrap them in the fabric.
So take some glue
and you glue it on
and this is what they look like.
Yeah,
and then it's a cute little banner you can hang.
But then you see this like, this is, it's crafty,
so it's not like,
Let's show 'em
how we use it.
it's not like over the top.
Yeah, so then you can just like,
hang it outside your door.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that is so awesome.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
It's sweet, but Erin's got an idea.
So look at this.
Yes.
Now this goes classy.
This does go classy.
You can clip some-
♪ Silver bells ♪
Yes, or,
♪ Galvanized buckets ♪
and you put bells on twine,
hanging inside your bell bucket,
and then, you can attach it to like,
greenery you've clipped out of the yard
and use this instead of a wreath
hanging on the front door.
So beautiful.
Sounds real festive when people come in.
Yeah.
Erin
and I are really big on clipping things
out of the yard, 'cause it's free.
But also you get the, like,
Look at that.
it makes you look
like you're those people that care a lot-
Yes
when you make
like, fresh arrangements.
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
I love that.
Yeah, we've got a nice little mix of both here.
You got, you know, some classy little trees.
You got a little bit of loud
and bombastic,
and then you got the classy bells
with the clippings from the yard.
A good mix.
I really think
it resonates with everybody.
You know, you can't go wrong,
and sincerely, that's why you're the taste-makers
of America now.
Wow, thank you.
You know, it's so true.
(audience clapping)
Whoa, she said it.
Thank you.
You just, you know, Forbes like,
power couple of the globe taste-makers.
That is absolutely what it is,
and People Magazine's highest selling issue, PS.
What?
I think you're on the cover twice too,
which is-
Oh wow.
unheard of in the space of a year.
Highest selling issue, really?
Highest selling issue.
You just told us that,
that's news.
Whoa.
Isn't that
nice to know?
Oh my gosh, Drew.
That's crazy.
I know.
I'm also in the Top 50 Sexiest Men Alive, so.
Yes you are.
(audience clapping)
Y'all, he cannot stop
I just wanted to make sure
telling people.
everyone know
that little detail, because there's only 50 of us alive.
(audience laughing)
William Shatner was ahead of him though, so.
Well Erin, I think, you know,
you're on the most beautiful, absolutely,
and you too Yvonne,
and we're gonna send these items home with you.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh
so you can just,
get your decorating on.
And I can't thank you enough, Ben
and Erin,
and Yvonne, for talking about just little things
we can do to boost our mood.
This is that mental wellness, that is that joy.
If you can come home
and see something you did,
that will spark that joy
and make you feel good
and express yourselves to your community,
this is very meaningful.
Honestly, I take it
real serious.
(audience clapping)
Good.
Absolutely.
It's important.
Wow, you almost got me crying there.
I know.
Make sure you check out the new season of Hometown
and Hometown Ben's Holiday Workshop,
premiering Sunday, December 26 on HGTV.
I'll be watching.
(upbeat pop music)